CBS Evening News anchor Jeff Glor is
along the oceanfront in Wilmington North
Carolina Jeff good morning Nora good
morning - we are on the waterfront here
where we are just starting to feel some
of the effects of Hurricane Florence
some of those tropical storm-force gusts
starting to come through as Lonnie
mentioned it did was downgraded to a
category 2 storm overnight that does not
mean anyone is out of danger the heavy
rainfall and storm surge still expected
to reach catastrophic levels especially
from that flooding all of it pushing
inland we have a team of correspondents
here along the coast covering the storm
we're gonna begin here this morning
right in Wilmington with David Wagner
David
Jeff good morning Wilmington is empty
you couldn't buy groceries around here
if you wanted to most everything is
closed down and then there are the
businesses that are boarded up in
downtown the only thing I see our police
officers riding around listen the winds
are starting to pick up we're told they
could get up to 50 miles an hour gusts
that could be today listen the one thing
I keep hearing Lonnie and others talk
about is don't just focus on the winds
focus on the rainfall and the surge and
what we could experience where we are in
this area just two miles from here is a
storm surge of up to 13 feet 13 feet my
friends that is as high as some homes in
this area the bottom line is
preparations are over it is go time
all right David thank you very much